I I believe we are live D I believe
we're live what's going on you guys
welcome back to the atct show we we talk
about the past present feature game I
got my Coast with me Dirk green what's
going on Dirk Xbox text adct oh wait
already like like no not no no go no
taking me out we going straight to the
straight to the the the main course is
that what we do no man you know you
listen brother we can talk about
whatever you want to my
brother yeah it's GNA be crazy man we we
got a pretty crazy show for you guys
there's a lot of stuff that's going into
place I
need talk to her so sorry my brother's
being rude it seems like everyone and
everyone's mom needs to have a
conversation with me right when I start
the podcast but the entire time all day
people have left me alone the moment I
start the podcast it's like it's like
there's a fifth six it's like we
something gotta happen but anyway you
know uh back to's what you been playing
what you been playing DK well sir I
finished Allan Wake
2 I enjoyed it um I wouldn't give it a
nine like everybody did but you know it
was a pretty decent game some slow Parts
most of Allan Wake missions to me were
kind of kind of boring but you know it
was fine and I just started Robocop and
I'm imagine that game is actually better
than I thought it would
be oh I haven't played it at all yeah
I'm actually enjoying it it's actually
much better than I thought it would
be yeah um that kind of game just ain't
for me man you know I'm not I'm not
about the you know fighting and the and
the you know I feel like if if your
whole intention is to catch me off guard
and hit me with a
hit me with a like a scare tactic then
it's just like is that is that all your
game really got going for well they
there's a lot of that there's a lot of
you know that little you know like when
they try to scare you with so yeah it's
definitely a lot of that just randomly
hear someone in the
next it's kind of sounds like um
Voldemort from Harry Potter yeah
something yeah oh my God man it's it's
it's it's crazy you know we we're going
to talk about Halo infinite uh I've been
playing that um Halo 3 rebranded maps
that's on Halo infinite I gota want to
talk about that we're g to talk about
the Battle Boulders Gate
3 looking like it actually might come
out uh the individual Dev had some stuff
to say we're going to go over that and
we're talk about this this this
Starfield and Xbox tag
not getting game of the year you know we
we got a lot I did do some research on
the Video Game Awards uh you know you
know what crazy D and I know you deal
with this too
yeah because we make Xbox content we
ain't allowed to criticize anything
that's not Xbox right you know I I'm
sitting here like I and I made the video
I made it yesterday and it was just
pretty much like
look some things about the Video Game
Awards don't make sense to me and I
would like to discuss it and we'll all
come together to determine does the
stuff I find makes sense or not one
would think that would be good enough
you know okay addict's not making
definite statements but you know he he's
just looking over this stuff so it's
it's crazy man you know and the people
sitting there say oh you're only like
this CUA Starfield didn't get nominated
D did I not say on multiple occasions on
this show on ILP that starf is
personally my top six but I can
understand if it's not the industry's
top six y so it's just like no that's
has nothing to do with it like uh I've
been a huge person about going after
Metacritic when it feels like the
industry can improve on it I'm a huge
person at going after the Video Game
Awards because I feel like it could
improve on it like you if you want
news repeated I am not the channel for
you I give my opinion and I talk [__] so
it's just
like I don't know
man let let's let's talk a little bit
out being an Xbox content creator DK
because u i I don't think people realize
how much scrutiny that [__] comes with
like like just because you want to make
content on Xbox and the reason I'm not
saying PlayStation content is because
those people they're like unicorns they
they rarely exist or or or they're just
extinct like I don't I couldn't really
name you Xbox content creators besides a
few that don't make cont that make
content on PlayStation and not Xbox like
like for the most part PlayStation cont
cares they're not they're not they're
not PlayStation channels they're anti
Xbox channels yeah uh there's very few
people that actually do what we do you
know you guys might clown on the
occasional PlayStation news but for the
most part all of your topics is Xbox
related true or false uh well well I got
to be honest not all the time um no I'm
saying
like there's a difference between
talking about stuff that's going on in
the industry right now and using that
that topping that that topic point every
week and attacking the same talking
point when you're talking about stuff
going on right now it's relevant because
it's going on right now but when you're
literally using the same talking points
every week that's not talking about the
industry that's talking about your
personal agendas yeah um well add you
know I'm I'm transparent and I say most
of my console war banter is geared
towards PlayStation Fanboys so sometimes
the easiest people to upset yeah exactly
so sometimes I might throw some anti-
PlayStation stuff in my my uh content
just to piss them off or you know just
to you know ruffle their feathers but at
the end of the day um yes I never said I
hated PlayStation I always say I
actually like PlayStation they're not
looking as great as some people make out
make it seem right now I mean they're
not Flawless they have some issues right
now but you know I don't hate
PlayStation but what you
said the the pro PlayStation
podcast um they're no different than
what some of the things that we do they
talk about Xbox Xbox Fanboys they have
names for xbox Fanboys you know it's the
same stuff man so if we're talking about
place news like you said they're in the
news I had people leave me
comments this supposed to be Xbox
Channel why you talking about
PlayStation the funny thing is there's a
difference between you talking about
okay Jim Ryan stepped down and talking
about the the for the 15th time why Game
Pass isn't going to be sustainable
that's a fact talking 15 times about how
Xbox hasn't made no quality games but if
you look besides redfall they've made
only 80 plus games for the most part
among the whole return pay you know
what's funny too people had that list of
all those games that didn't have like
nominations yeah and I'm like okay so I
guess we're not counting the out of
Worlds because they bought it the year
before they the game shipped yeah I
guess I guess we're not talking didn't
Psychonauts get nominated too 100% And
and you what's funny is the the company
that made Psychonauts literally said
without Microsoft allowing them to go
back to the drawing board and fill in
those boss battles you can argue that
that g Got Game of the Year because of
Xbox it wasn't it because of of the
previous publisher they gave them the
financial backing to go back to the
drawing board and say yo you obviously
if you guys want to put this in here
it's GNA make it a better game go and do
that yep 100% um and that happened
because remember they acquired double
find in 2019 they got nominated for Game
of the Year in 2021 they've been they
were on Xbox for two years and like you
said they
said this game will be totally different
if it wasn't for
Xbox yeah wasteline three I don't think
that game got nominated but it was a
phenomenal game and you know they they
said that they put multiple boss fights
in that game because they they allowed
them to delay it too and go back to to
to the drawing board and pick up some of
the things that was cut from the ground
floor and put it back in the game right
people don't want to talk about that
though they don't want to talk about the
fact that Starfield got two extra years
of development
time two years they don't want to talk
about the fact that Indiana Jones was
supposed to come out last year so
clearly Microsoft is valuing quality
over quantity but they don't want to
talk about that they want to carry the
same narrative because of something that
happened with redfall redfall was
extremely underwhelming and no one is
co-signing that but we cannot act like
that is not the exception not the rule
right or however they like to say yeah
yeah I got you brother no you're right
about that and and it's like when redar
came out they act like
red was was Crackdown or or State of
Decay they act like red fall was what
Xbox has been doing for the past three
or four years no we like you said they
won publisher of the year in
2021 but people didn't want to give them
credit they said oh well cyon KN 2 was
in development before Xbox acquired them
yeah that's true but as you just said
because they were on the Xbox they were
able to finish the game how they they
had to literally take out all of the
bosses because they did not have the
funds I'm I'm sorry D I just realized
when I like on the steam deck I put I
put soles Twitter is your twter oh yeah
you did yeah what's funny is I have a
bot that tweets that naturally you'll
start seeing them tweet I think yours is
every 34 minutes that's even on IL like
that even pops up on IP and what what's
interesting is uh I put I put cogs as
yours and I had to go back and fix that
so that one's right but I got to go back
and fix that one too because I have them
all on my steam deck where I push a
button it just throws uh you know a
Twitter handle in there hey um cry said
are we not C death Loop yeah death Loop
was another game because and that was a
good game a lot of people didn't like
that but I enjoyed it was different but
I enjoyed it I finished it I enjoyed it
it took me a minute to understand
exactly how to play it but once I got it
I loved it yeah like my uh you know it
just the part that irritates me is like
we look obviously there's going to be
your bad apples in the Xbox Community
people that want to like spoil uh
Spider-Man 2 for no reason uh you know
even spoiling it for someone like myself
I get it those people are very toxic and
I don't coign that but I'm not going to
condemn them either because it's like
I'm sure they were spoiled on on
Starfield I don't cosign it I don't
think you should be doing that but at
the same time you know sometimes people
take stuff a little too farther like uh
I had Starfield you know stuff spoil for
me so I'm G get them back but to me you
that's a blank statement that you're
attacking multiple people for for no
reason you know there's no there's no
timeline where you're not spoiling it
for people that actually that that you
mess with and and there there's my thing
but it's like even those bad apples on
Xbox you know I see the majority of the
Xbox Community maybe it's just me may
may maybe it's just the people I follow
but when a when a dope game comes out
like Spider-Man 2 besides the bugs and
you know God of War Ragnarok you know
Horizon forbidden West I see more Xbox
people giving props yo that's a good
game you know obviously you got the bad
apples and there gon to be bad apples
and everything but I feel like there's
bad apples on Xbox and there's rotten
apples on Playstation like it just
sometimes just be like real messy for no
reason it's like dude we don't have to
go this far talking about people's
families and stuff it's like dude this
is this is video games my dude like calm
down yeah I agree man um even my channel
bro like in the past God of War I say I
love the game last of us two last of us
one I love those games
so when a Xbox game comes out no matter
what some of these PlayStation guys will
bash it destroy it kill it like
if Us Xbox guys we're noticing okay like
me personally I can't speak for
everybody I noticed when Modern Warfare
2 score dropped and it was a
four I saw some PlayStation guys go out
there and say Xbox is trash you know
what's funny let me interrupt let me
interrupt you though they want to give
Call of Duty credit they want to give
Call of Duty credit for Xbox Xbox took
him over that's why but when Star came
out that's Bethesda when what's funny is
when when came out that was Microsoft
too yeah no what's funny is is it's like
I said when Psychonauts came out that's
that that's uh whatever that company's
called I always forget their name double
find when out of Worlds came out that's
obsidian and it's like well they game
they just bought him six months ago it's
like fam they just bought Activision two
weeks ago and you trying to give Xbox
credit for that
score Addy I seen the tweets this is
Xbox and they had a tweet with modern
warfare score people say Xbox dudes have
a PlayStation 2 oh yeah I
do this is like the fourth controller I
have like because my my girlfriend's
brother's in there with the the custom
one that uh hex gaming shout out to XX
gaming they sent me uh he's in there
playing Spider-Man too so hold on so but
look truth
sound that's you're so you said they
claim K's first party it is first party
right now right so if K would have got a
n out of 10 y'all wouldn't have gave
Xbox credit for it but because they got
a four out of 10 y'all giving XBox Four
credit for it listen we're not I haven't
seen um many Xbox guys shy away from
Call of Duty being an Xbox game actually
some Xbox guys are saying because Call
of Duty is a Xbox game is getting hit
yeah and I've seen people on the Xbox
side look that were work uh you know the
these developers are being worked to the
Bone like they they need to get a little
bit of break so like these quality games
are separated so there's actually good
quality and it just improves and not wor
having four teams working on Call of
Duty and it's like okay you got two
years to make it technically three I
think there's three teams making Call of
Duty but you know I see more like a year
and a half though like War Zone 3 I'm
sorry like Warfare 3 that's crazy I I
see more Xbox people coming up with
solutions to the problem and not just
Clowning the problem it's like everyone
has a gred for years we don't need Call
of Duty every year we need war zone
updates every year absolutely but we
don't need Call of Duty every year you
know let that be on a a year you know a
by-ear thing and I guarantee you the
quality of that game skyrockets and not
to mention you could probably okay you
know we're going to make we're going to
have we're going to merge two of the
studios one team's going to work on uh
so I would say merge Infinity war and
Treyarch now obviously they're not
together they're still two individual
companies but they're in one team now so
you know you you
have a set amount of people constantly
you know the majority of the the staff
constantly working on war zone and U you
know they're always popping out content
over and over again that makes sense and
then you have you know probably like 70
to 100 people people they're working on
the next Call of Duty story thing and
it's going to be two years from now so
instead instead of them having so long
of a thing that they'll have four years
instead of two now because there's
another Studio doing it as well it
just it's just it irritates me it it
does and then people sit there and every
time you you criticize anything people
try to dismiss you just because you're
an Xbox channel it's like dude shut up
shut up like what's funny is like I I I
call Out PlayStation I call out Xbox but
the thing is is they want me to be in an
echo chamber with them I've always said
for the moment I know you a little bit
different I want critical voices in my
community and that's fine I don't want
[__] in my community I think you can
agree with that you know if we can't
have a civil conversation I want you out
of my community because it's just like
if you're going straight to oh adct you
did this because of that then you ain't
watching me you're making your
own mindset on who I am and judging me
as a character off of other people's
opinions and I guarantee you that
happens more than people think yeah so
so I say is a dude in the
chat Mexican zoy B your Xbox dudes are
so whiny oh yeah look at that we're
whiny right we're whiny okay I would
love to see how you f to buy the ABK
deal I would love to see that I
guarantee you was probably crying don't
let Xbox buy them it's not right it's
not fair they're the Big Bad Evil
Corporation shut up
P someone said you don't have uh you
don't call out so uh Nintendo because I
gave up on Nintendo Nintendo gonna do
what Nintendo wants to do there ain't
nothing I could do about it I could
scream from the top of my lungs Nintendo
don't care if you bash them on Twitter
Nintendo care if you don't buy their
game because it's 10 million people that
will buy their game Nintendo don't care
if the media comes after them Nintendo
don't care if if social uh media Outlets
go after them saying they're sexist
racist Nintendo don't care what you say
like yeah they don't because they they
have their loyal fan base and they gonna
sell
regardless yeah so all right you know
we're gonna goad and move on we're going
to move on to Halo man tell me please
tell me you've been looking at this Halo
stuff
no I haven't bro I I did see they added
some Halo 3 was it Maps what's going on
with it because I I'm out of the loop
bro I'm sorry so all right so we're 19
minutes in man we talked about that for
a minute all right so we're we're 19
minutes in pretty much what they've done
is they've made a Halo in in Halo
infinite they've I think it's Community
Based now people let me get this Super
Chat real quick before we forget about
it got a $5 Super Chat for the angry
therapist
adct dirt
your content has been fir since the
announcement about
announcement oh I feel man shout out to
Ang therapist man I feel so they they
pretty much went back and you know
correct me if I'm wrong I'm sure someone
in the chat will uh I don't know if
they're Community Based or you know or
like 343 themselves made it so
definitely put in there uh correcting me
if I'm wrong I think it's communitybased
because I see by on the bottom left but
it seems like if it is community based
they've tooken they've took not took
they've took like probably six or seven
of the most popular maps that was in
Halo 3 and they've been redefined and
put into Halo infinite as a playlist may
I add so I was playing like what they
call the pit now not the pit what they
call Guardian I don't know what it's
name it's like a s name or something
like that but they got it weird now now
like the top platform has a hole in it
and like a little guard on the sides so
you could jump down and the the little
thing at the bottom you could jump up
like they they they've they've made a
lot of like really refreshing changes to
accommodate to like the fast pacing type
of gameplay you're gonna have in here
and what what I what I find interesting
is just how they're doing it you know
they they brought back all these Halo 3
maps and it looks like you know they're
probably going to expand on that they
made it to
where you could get XP on anything from
the last updates they did So you you're
not punished for going out there and and
experiencing new maps so they did a
really good job on that like an
irritation I have with the Video Game
Awards is why wasn't Halo infinite in
that best ongoing or best community like
because to me it's just like you could
have took cyber Punk off that sucker why
was cyk be adct I don't know I I I they
Dr some
DLC the part the funny thing is like
when I brought that video up I just
questioning the process D like and okay
I will say I got it wrong see right
there I got it streamlabs it says your
name you're correctly uh that's the bot
doing it um you know when it comes to
that it's like what's what I'm looking
for I I did get it wrong there is a list
of the nominations but they're not easy
to find you have to really look through
the uh through the website to find it
and okay I'll admit I got that wrong but
my the reason I kept the video up
because I consider taking it down after
I saw that but I was like you know what
because I saw people in the comment
section my point still stands what's the
process to even getting on this list who
picks this list right because Jeff is
reaching out to these
people I just I'm curious like okay IOP
we're we're coming bigger and bigger
every year does IOP have a chance at
becoming on this list or or is it like a
VIP room that you can that you have to
have their mindset to get
in like kind of funny in it oh they are
oh yeah yeah so it's just
like I don't understand when you see
like hogwart's Legacy we'll get back
kind of funny is one of the people that
that helps with the
nominations yeah yes kind of funny the
pony podcast kind of funny yes thank you
so you know I'm looking at stuff like
this that's what I saw I I I think they
are but I you look at Halo it's just
like dude Halo did a lot this year Halo
like I still have my issues with Halo
I'm looking at Halo I played it
today
so my issue with Halo is I still think
the Cosmetics are hot garbage unless you
pay real money to get them and people
like oh that you know that's Cosmetics
like it's kind of the point as a games
is a service yeah I was about to say
that I mean but what it is want to to
grind get your favorite you know get the
get the emote everyone has which they
don't have emotes get that's the point
and when they're very underwhelming it's
a little frustrating you know I'm
sitting here looking through this like
season or I don't know if it was like an
event or a season and I'm looking
through these and nothing looks
appealing
nothing I'm like what do they really
think people are going to grind to like
have like
a chest piece that comes out just a
little bit you know what I'm saying like
it's it's just like there's not enough
that's
intentional they they want you to go and
spend the money for
it that's the thing that's what gers
that servers is I feel them on that but
there's better ways to do it you know
they maybe have an in-game currency that
you could earn through doing matches and
you're able to spend that in-game
currency on like a rotating list or the
ch system they currently have now the
stuff in that store this game to me this
game is not popular enough to be asking
$20 for a for a set yeah that's a lot
that's a lot $20 yeah $20 for a set and
some and some paint it's not that it's
not popular enough they're not fortnite
and at least fortnite can sell you
products of stuff you watch in other
Medias like anime Marvel celebrity yeah
yeah ra yeah they are not that popular
and they need to stop acting like that
you know that that whole set should be
10 bucks five ideally should be 10 bucks
not not not 20 it's like and I think
it's a little bit
more so Nintendo d talking said I you
tripping just with the battle there are
some decent stuff in the battle passes
but it's not common you know some battle
passes are misses some aren't I'm not
saying
that that the battle passes have nothing
I'm saying that like ratio like this
event I looking at this event there
wasn't really a lot in this event that
appealed to me like at all like I looked
through it like one time it was like
yeah I'm good like you know and it's
like look you're going to get a lot of
people that play this
game and they don't care about the
rewards but the problem is stuff like
fortnite has showed that you have to
reward people for their
activities and if you're not rewarding
people effectively and people say well
addict people do pay $20 yes they do and
is it good though that's the question is
it keeping people engaged yeah there's
people in there but let me ask you this
if they had engaging Cosmetics or the
Cosmetics some of them that's in
whatever their store is in the battle
pass would they keep people in the game
longer trying to get
that would they keep people in their
friends longer trying to get that cuz we
know that we we know this just as well
DK you know I'll be sitting there you be
like yo add uh come and come and play
this this this uh this Halo infinite
with me now you've gotten me on Halo
infinite but if you weren't grinding for
your [__] you ain't getting me
on so you're literally just getting
people on that just likes the the loop
the gameplay Loop of Halo infinite and
that's fine that's that's awesome but
I'm telling you the gamers of today the
people like my brother's age the people
who play fortnite the people who play
War Zone they're used to flashy
cosmetics and Halo infinite does not
have a lot of
that I got you I got you I mean maybe
eventually it will get there because
like you know this is a game out of
service but you know I don't know man
you know um maybe they're trying to do
things their way you know I don't know
so yeah and that that's just my opinion
on the matter look
I I'm not SE some stuff like like Donal
taku said when I played not too long ago
I seen some some like damn where he get
that from or like you know how you kill
kill somebody something pops up you know
when you kill somebody like what do you
call
those when you kill somebody some type
of Animation show up and that's cool but
it's like I guarantee you a lot of that
[__] you got to buy in that in their
store so it's just like like sure
there's some of that stuff that is in
the game pass like in not g pass in the
in the battle pass but to
me I would say having people spend that
money it's just important keeping them
there too yeah because they'll pop in
there and spend that 20 bucks and never
they'll play a couple games and never
jump back on on Halo sure they gonna
love that 20 but you know what they
would have loved that 20 kept him in the
battle pass get earning more armor and
he spent another 20 next week yeah I
mean but like somebody said who like who
said that uh Alvin said it don't have to
be fortnite I understand fortnite is the
most popular um but you know Halo they
don't have a battle royale yet maybe
when a battle royale come they're going
to do some of those things you know you
never
know yeah it's just one of those things
you know they're doing a very good job
you know the Halo infinite game gameplay
has always been very addicting it's
always been a good solid uh gameplay
Loop but sometimes you especially you're
competing with people like fortnite
fortnite literally just went back to the
original OG map that they had like five
six years ago and the numbers took off
you saw yeah and it's just
like you you really think you're GNA
compete with the amount of content that
fortnite can deliver in a season by
making people pay for it like let's be
honest here like when you go on fortnite
fortnite's very given they give you
in-game currency when you buy season
pass uh now see here's the thing their
model is you can spend 10 bucks and you
could continue to max out that that that
uh that battle pass and you could
consistently
get the the battle pass every season as
long as you max it out and get the like
in-game currency they give you for the
for that but they know you're not going
to because you know what's gonna happen
D you're gonna pop in there with that
currency and you're gonna see oh yo that
looks hot like and you're gonna spend it
so then guess what not only are they
spending on the Cosmetics that's in the
item shop they're also spending more
money on the next battle pass because
fortnite has realized it is more
beneficial to make people look nice now
and keep them engaged and sell them [__]
later than is to [__] sell [__] now and
keep them and and lose them later
because there's nothing else to do know
you can say what you about fortnite
almost every page on fortnite got
something that looks interesting yeah
and see Pogo said not everyone plays
fortnite there's more people playing
fortnite than not playing fortnite in
the gaming
[Laughter]
industry yeah that's all I'm saying you
know my brother he he's a he's a big
halo fan you know it just I want them to
do better man I want I want Halo infin
to come in there and just
just take fortnite spot take infinite SP
uh Halo I want all that but to me they
they they got it they got to improve on
stuff you know I like that they
Incorporated stuff into it like you
could buy season passes any times you
want yeah that's cool but there's just
not a lot of cool stuff in these season
passes I want to say one thing that is
that is the best thing they added was
the season pass where you can switch
between them you don't have to sit here
be like either I buy it now grind it or
I lose it forever because that's one of
the most frustrating things let me ask
you a question do in your honest opinion
from someone that plays Halo a lot do
you think that the cosmetics and the
battle passes are are worth the money no
they're not they're they're cool but
they're not first off you got to pay to
get them you gotta pay to get the battle
pass and then you got to use your time
to get the actual Cosmetics the only
battle pass that I would even consider
dumping money into was the reach one
yeah no is the new one they just had the
infection one I haven't se the infection
one they have an event going on too
right now yeah seen the event has
nothing the event has
nothing and I get it people say it's hot
takes I get it you know but the the
that's my brother these are people that
play Halo you know and I'm not saying
people in the chat don't play Halo I'm
not saying dirt don't play Halo I'm just
telling you people that play Halos
opinions on the matter that's all no no
no more no less I guess
you let me get this Super Chat we got a
$10 Super Chat from ja 82 I will say
this I was frustrated with the Xbox and
some of the decisions they made they
came a long way they rebounded
PlayStation don't value their customers
or what they won't uh want changes
nothing well nothing
changes completely 100% agree
PlayStation is full of themselves they
think no one's going to ever leave their
platform and what's funny is like you
know right now you might be doing good
right now you might not have no issues
but what happens after a generation of
not of treating people like
crap look man I think at at one point a
lot of us was frustrated with Xbox but
you can deny like you just said ja 82
like you you can deny what Xbox has done
We complain about no first party Studios
not enough games no new IPS we're
relying on Halo gears and forer and Xbox
fixed that man
they fixed it by any means necessary
people said Xbox will you fix it will
you compete then when they did it said
no not like that that's not organic no
listen I don't care man Xbox um the
content that Xbox has on the way is
unmatched at this point at this point
PlayStation road map doesn't look
nowhere near as good as Xbox road map so
oh what road map exactly what road map
you you're comparing a it's like looking
at a blueprint and you see a whole
magnificent blueprints that's you know
IM imitating the the Golden Gate Bridge
and you look at PlayStation it's just a
blank paper with like a little slab at
the beginning like it's like and people
sit there I I honestly think you know
people people call me crazy but I think
you're there's gonna be a lot of
comparison Jim Ryan to Don matcher
because I think he took the brand in the
wrong direction for for like three years
and that's not easy to recuperate from
that's not easy to balance back
from it probably take them a whole
generation to fix the stuff that he put
them in add the only difference between
Xbox uh and Microsoft I mean and uh
Playstation as far as Jim Ryan and Don
matrick when Don matrick did it at the
beginning of a generation and hurt Xbox
so bad they're still recovering they're
still trying to get some of those people
they lost in the Xbox 360s generation
bro they're still trying to get some of
those people
back when Jim Ryan messed up PlayStation
they were already at top at the top
right and and because you know like
every time there's a new generation
things start over so that even though
the 360 was like more popular than a
three than a
PS3 in certain areas of the world the
Xbox One like d modrick botched the Xbox
One launch so bad that people went to
PlayStation 4 and drove
and like I said some of those people
haven't returned so Jim Ryan what he has
done with the PlayStation brand at it
you said it it's gonna take them a while
to
recover he and clearly you know what's
funny you don't have to look any further
PlayStation agrees with us they've had a
complete 180 restructuring of their
whole bu they fired his ass get out of
here so yeah they agree with us and it's
like they fired anyone that even
remotely believed I don't know if Cony
like a approved of what he was doing but
it's like you got to go too because you
didn't check that man you let that man
run wild you got to go too and I don't
know what happened with that I don't
think we'll ever know and people saying
Wolverine's coming out next year I got
some swamp Islands I want to sell you
to whoever think Wolverine coming out
next
year highly unlikely highly unlikely
people say well addict Insomniac could
pop a game out every two years they
literally just launch Spider-Man 2 even
if two years was possible that's 2025 my
d That's not
2024 and the reason they've been able to
get games out so fast is because they're
efficient and because they had already
pre-built assets for a lot of these
games Spider-Man when they built the
original Ratchet and Clank they could
build on from RI Rift apart because of
the work they did on Ratchet and Clank
when they built Spider-Man 2 they were
able to do it so quickly because they
were able to go off of what they did for
miles and what they did for Spider-Man
2018 same city the same city they just
put a new region in and that's cool no
one's attacking quality the quality of
the game is besides the bugs when it
came out you know there was more in
there than just spiders you know besides
the bugs it it it functioned really well
the game functioned well the game
mechanics did well but it's just like
look I won't be real with you Wolverine
early 2020 earliest 2025 I would say
2026 is more realistic yeah um so yeah I
agree with that but I just feel that he
hurt PlayStation bro like listen
PlayStation is going to continue to sell
consoles and that's fine they're a
they're a massive brand very popular
brand um and as we
see when it comes to the the PS5 is the
is the console that the casuals chose so
exclusive games might not matter as much
at this point um maybe in a console war
we're going to talk a lot of trash yes
we are but you know the casuals chose
the PlayStation so them not having many
first-party games right now I I don't
think it's going to hurt them because as
you seen their their uh most um uh like
what is it the most uh play games or or
the most engagement
list fortnite was still number one you
know so and that's the month that's
Spider-Man came out so fortnite was
still number one as far as engagement of
course Spider-Man sold the most
obviously fortnite is free but it just
goes to show you that PlayStation is
doing great there there sales but Don
Massy did hurt the brand because he
literally spent money on Bungie Haven
firew walk deviation not deviation fire
Sprite some of these Studios strictly
for games out of service and I know they
said they're they're delaying half of
those games as a service they're
dropping six of them delaying I believe
most of those six that's delayed some of
those are probably canc yeah and I think
the I think because if you look at it
now do they get rid of some of them do
first off do they
consider do they consider Marathon one
I'm curious on that probably uh do they
consider Destiny's ongoing projects one
that's a good question so like Destiny 3
if they do a destiny 3 like do they
consider that one uh what do they
consider consider Drive Club because I
know that was considered one of their
games as a service is that one that's
all not drive Club Drive not Grand triso
do they consider Grand triso one that's
already been made or do they consider
that as one of their games as a service
so if you start to really start to
eliminate some of these we're getting in
a weird situation here because that
means the six that we
think is six is just Marathon Destiny 2
uh you know hell divers uh the the
Twisted Metal I'm pretty sure that's one
like they I don't think they'd count NBA
uh the show but I know they do count the
show as one of them so do that mean the
shows one see here's the thing people
sitting there and say delusional we're
just asking questions it's not my fault
you don't like the questions I didn't
invent a question I'm just asking Los
adct because this is this what what the
the uh CEO well like what is he like
haki Takaki whatever his name is he said
it but we're delusional because he said
they're count well they're delaying six
other games as the service but we're
delusional where the guy that's running
that took Jim Ryan spot temporarily
we're Del losion but he said
it look PlayStation will be fine but I
do think you guys are in for a dry spell
that you not going to believe exists
it's goingon to be a hell of a dry spell
that y'all ain't used to but trust me
it's about to happen be prepared for it
2023 was in a a dry spout to them in
some ways because you know people want
to sit there and
say what what is Xbox without Bethesda
what the hell is Sony without squar Enix
facts you know they they there's going
to be some but here's that they're still
going to have good games because they've
made arrangements and deals with people
they're going to have games like you
know Final Fantasy they're still going
to have good games but you know some of
these games that you guys are looking
forward to the ghost of shishima 2
that's some beeping your background yeah
it's over now the ghost of Shima too
there's certain games that you guys are
looking forward to I'm curious if it's
even close to being done that's my thing
n gota say a storm is coming weird look
how mad we are we listen we're mad
because y'all ain't got no games coming
we're mad so we're we're mad because
y'all Ain got no games coming we got G
and you know what's funny you know
what's funny people sit there and the
the flam us and say well you know all
you guys is got get Got Game Pass so I'm
not saying that game pass is ever going
to be a a replacement to really good you
know first party support but what I will
say is it helps you know I got Persona
tactics coming out tomorrow you know we
payday to they just had the ninja
guidance like look I'm not saying the
Xbox
people my thing is they give us this
stream because they're like look we
don't really got a lot going right now
so you know let's just have them playing
games so they're not on Twitter bitching
and I'm G tell you one thing add it
these guys want to try to pull out these
lists with all these third party games
hey don't do it because I'm telling you
you guys roasted Xbox for not having
when boox show has some third party
exclusives y'all said that doesn't count
they're not first
party oh yeah I remember I remember so
don't y'all come out here with these
third party um list these third party
well we got uh a final fantasy rebirth
we got this nah we're talking about
first party remember first party is the
only thing that mattered to you guys so
don't come out here with these lists now
don't don't don't do
it might not might not want to make
those those those lists because Xbox
might buy the studio
exactly y'all depending on KY for that
extra money look Kyle is still selling
well on both platforms oh look at n
third party equals games boy don't have
me go to my phone and pull out some
receipts about how you guys how how not
not you Nixie personally but I have some
receipts PlayStation guys saying third
party games don't count don't play play
with me
man and it's like look I'm never going
to sit there and tell you they don't
need first party they need first party
but it's like it's a lot harder for me
to complain when tomorrow I'm playing
another game and then there's another
game coming out in like a week like this
year has been very lucrative if you're a
Game Pass subscri subscriber like you're
playing pretty much something every week
to two the beeping has gone guys okay
the microwave has been opened I
apologize I can't help it the problem is
is like my computer setup is like right
next to to the kitchen so most of the
time it's not really an issue but when I
do the atct show in particular it's not
like IOP where other people are talking
for 40 minutes before I talk like you
mute yourself right like you mute
yourself but yeah when you I get it yeah
now if I know it's not going to go away
for a couple minutes I'll ask you to
talk for a couple minutes and and I'll
handle it but I knew someone was coming
to get they food you people always going
to come back and get their food yeah all
right they wouldn't have made it if they
weren't gonna come back and get it I
hope not but it's just like my thing
dude is just like people just need to
get over themselves it's like the the
world doesn't revolve around you guys I
I I know you guys think you do it just
doesn't yep yeah you know look man um
PlayStation is going to be fine they're
going to continue to sell ps5s but all
we're saying is let's be prepared cuz
it's about to be super dry out there I
saw somebody said Popeye biscuit
dry and which is you know listen man I
pop back biscuit while extremely good
you definitely need a beverage when you
eat one because it's gonna be super dry
man but hey man Xbox we definitely had
dry ears yeah and we're gonna no
actually I'm gonna take that back I
don't think we're gonna have a dry ear
for a long time
yeah22 was at the last drybox they have
more dry Years bro we'll at least have
two two games a year big games every
year from now on like I unless unless
they decide to get rid of some of the
studios with the current output that
they're able to do now I'd be very
surprised yeah if I mean next year we're
probably gonna have hellblade 2 for sure
um we do have some that Parker game that
they did the tower borne or whatever it
is yep looks
fun good chance Indiana Jones hits next
year a vow because they said a v AOW
four I mean that's just four we're not
even talking about like what they do
with Game Pass yeah I'm sure a Starfield
expansion because coming out next year
I'm sure they're gonna do more stuff
with Halo like like it's like I said in
a video a a little bit like PlayStation
would kill to have the games as a
service that Xbox has yeah like I was
told no clock War work is not coming out
next year probably well like 2025 though
I'm thinking Clock Works more like 20 26
2 27 like really why so why would they
show it this early I think they just
wanted to show it I think they're being
a little bit more comfortable the thing
is is people aren't going to complain if
they have stuff to play you know we
might see this game clock work and
people might ask where it is next year
but if you're giving them stuff to play
they're not going to really complain too
much you know what I'm saying yeah see
that's the you know what that's the one
thing I would say that's the difference
between Xbox now as opposed to the Xbox
one generation
they didn't have many games so they had
to put out games like recore a state K
to that wasn't really finished but they
had to put it out because they had no
other games now they're not going to
have that issue man they're G to put
these games out um with the exception
the red fall of course um but but
they're going to put these games out
because when they're ready because they
have so much content Contraband hey yo
Jonathan Cox I forgot about Contraband
hey add where you think that's coming
out they got to be 2025 at least right
beginning 2025 maybe late 2024 yeah
because counter band they they
announcing in 2021 here's how I think
it's gonna go now I don't know I don't
know uh this is just off of things I've
heard and progressions I've heard in the
background I think AOW is next year fa
was
2025 I think Indiana Jones is either
next year or early 20
25 I think gears is 2026
2027 hell blades next year start perfect
darts 2026
2027 uh outter Worlds 2 is probably 2026
South the midnight south of Midnight's
probably
2025 Elder Scrolls is probably 2026 2027
so much
content um let me see uh something else
um did you say perfect dark yes 2026
2027 now what about some of the rumored
games like iio dragon game or uh someone
says State K State of K I would I
actually I think we might you know we
might
see we might see might see it next year
you think you might see it see it next
year but it come out in 2025 no I I'm
not referring to that I'm referring to
um the next
Doom I think you might see Doom next
year you know I forgot because remember
phield sprc was really excited about
whatever ID is working on yeah and I
think I think Doom has been working on a
prequel just like it was in that leak
yeah we're not even a Fallout 3 I think
that's the uh probably Fallout 3 is
weird I think oblivion's quick closer to
the Fallout 3 I think you'll see
Oblivion next year dang ever while ever
wildre it's
cancel I'm willing to say ever wild it's
probably that's not confirmation it's
this is your opinion right yeah in my
opinion they will eventually close the
doors in every while okay because so
that's not official I just just adct
opinion y yeah adct opinion I don't have
no I have no contacts at rare I'm just
saying we haven't heard nothing from
them in years but we continue to see
updates on C thieves and I have been
told sea of Thieves is a money printing
machine I believe make a lot of money
off sea of Thieves I believe it so you
know they might still have have ever
wildad come out but to me it's been
years and we haven't even have an update
not even he they rebooted it though yeah
but still even rebooting you see
something by now like something like we
haven't eared nothing kima's
game maybe next year oh you think
they'll show it next year or they might
show it next year I don't
know think about all of this content
we're talking about ad and they still
have so much so much stuff they haven't
announced and this this isn't talking
about games and game pass this isn't
about this isn't time exclusives either
because you know they're still going to
do that there still have some form of
timed exclusivity my stalker too yeah uh
this isn't talking about games that
haven't been
announced because we know some of these
studios are have two teams working on
stuff
so I don't know U you know and this
isn't talking about by the time these
games come
out the other games are going to start
release hey you know I'm glad you said
that because I I can't wait to see what
Arcane Leon you know the people to make
death what their next game is GNA be
which I totally believe is gonna be
Dishonored three that's dishonor three
and I I think I think your boy gonna be
in the game Who Co for real oh [__] they
they already said that they're in the
same
universe oh yeah suck good whock I think
you have a dishonor three and you know
it would be crazy and I know it would
never happen but it would be intense and
I would I'd hate it and I'd love it at
the same time if you're Colt and the
main bad guys
corvo yo listen I love this out I love
part one part two I even beat the
DLC I love death flop that's fire bro
but think about because that flute came
out 2021 right yeah
2021 2026 they should be ready for it
you know what I'm saying we might see
something on them next year it's all
people sitting there they they talking
all this [__] they don't understand
about to hit them they don't know it man
you know yeah I get it it's hard here
here's the thing if people come at me
say addict Xbox has been so dry for so
many of the times I've wanted them to
have games I can't put my trust in them
100% agree with that that's fine then
just wait for the games but some of
these people on Twitter you know for
someone that doesn't have an Xbox your
ass talks about an Xbox quiet a lot
right hey I heard a clip uh adct on um
it was a clip that was in some Twitter
spaces you know and this one guy he said
this one PlayStation guy he
said Xbox still is not
aggressive B ABK is a one aggressive ass
move well let me say this because the
guy who who was hosting it he went off
on the guy said what the f is wrong with
you spending $69 billion isn't
aggressive
so I think what the PlayStation got
their mentality for whatever reason
their mentality is it's still the Xbox
One version of Xbox even though Xbox is
out here buying investing their content
looks incredible mentally some of these
PlayStation guys still think this is the
Xbox One version of Xbox the ones that
didn't have many games or many games in
development for this guy to say yo
they're still not aggressive what the
hell do you
mean they're not aggressive spend buying
ABK buying Bethesda taking Starfield off
of PlayStation taking red fall off of
PlayStation hay R red fall or not they
took it off a PlayStation so some of
these guys they're still not aggressive
enough and it's ridiculous it's
ridiculous so I'm glad that guy went off
on the
pony
yeah I don't be liking the way people be
handling that stuff man it's like I'm
never gonna
condone and I feel like we can do better
everyone could do better even my even my
uh rude ass you know I don't claim to be
professional I'm just
me and people were like addict you toned
down your your opinions you did this you
done that it's like fam I just realized
I was being too much for no reason I
used to have a clipboard on my phone
with insults for people in comment
sections that's interesting because
because I was writing so many of them
and started copying them on my clipboard
wow yeah I used to go I you you know me
videos they're on my channel now where
like if you see if you see a a video on
my channel that's like respond and has a
YouTube icon it's a [__] talking
video you know I was a I was a toxic
[__] I was like there no denying that
I used to you know I used to respond in
ill ways on Twitter I'm gonna be real
with you the crumb side snatched me up
when I first got on YouTube it's hard
not to jump into that pool you know
people sit there and they
say
addict it's if I ever did this I
wouldn't jump and you say that now when
you make 10 15 videos and it gets five
views and you make that one even semi
console war video and it gets 500 yeah
and you're like oh
maybe I found a cheat
code hey you know what's funny I
remember when I told you my my second my
first video on my channel was I was
bashing Nintendo switch and I got like
2,000 views bro my first video and and
tell me that
wasn't it's like on drugs like you're
looking at it you think oh I did it it
made it hey add I thought it was easy my
next four videos got 30 combined 30
views combined right then I did a video
about Nintendo again said I'm tired of
Nintendo getting a pass that video got
like 177,000 views bro this is back when
I had 40 subscribers oh so so
essentially you're telling me you could
have been an anti- Nintendo Channel if
you embraced it yeah but you know back
then you know dislikes you know like we
can see the dislikes so my dislikes was
like I had 200 likes 800 dislikes right
so then when I started doing more Xbox
content bro it was a slow grind I would
get 30 views 40 views then when I reach
the 100 views he wa so I understand
exactly what you're saying man you know
for you people that's trying to be all
nice and you get no views and they use
some console war stuff then your views
go up you're like oh
interesting yeah people talking about
Super Mario RPG I'll be playing that I
think that comes out
tonight yeah I'm gonna be playing that
all weekend I already told my girl
you told her in advance yeah I I've I've
I've learned that if if I communicate
when uh when she'll get less of my my
time it's it's less fighting when it
happens that's cool man just let it know
hey man like when I um before I married
my wife and we married 20 years now but
I told her listen I play video games
sweetheart meaning don't bother me with
my damn video games and I told her that
up front bro this is the true story I
told her that up front because my
ex-wife she always had a damn problem
with me in my video games bro she always
like why you playing damn game Let's
watch TV like [__] I don't know why to
watch TV excuse me I don't want to watch
TV I want to play video games right now
so she always had a problem with it told
my current wife yo I play video it's
like I don't drink I don't do drugs I I
don't cheat I don't cheat let me have my
thing
man hey D Togo say was that the shimu
wife yeah that's that's the one that had
issues with video games not my current
wife my current wife don't have no
problem bro yeah plus you know she she's
she's pretty solid when it comes to you
know I told her I said look look babe in
February in
February that Final Fantasy 7 rebirths
coming out I was like you need your
space I and I was like and she now
she'll ask me for
examples okay is it is it like woong
time or is it like starfi time it's like
it's
probably this is probably gonna make you
have another
example I was like I don't want to give
you any
definit because I don't know what
they're gonna
be I I lowkey want to
say it's gonna be
more fact you you haven't came across me
in a Final Fantasy game yet one that I
love
right oh my God they said dirt dropping
marriage advice this man you got to be
transparent man yeah most of them are
are cool as long as you're transparent I
don't know how we done did this we're
we're going to the next topic the to's
been like a really like chill we gonna
talk about all right bers gate three we
have tempted to go into this one already
but
somehow it's not even somehow we we just
did it on
purpose BS gate three is is officially
coming to
Xbox so we've known about it for a while
but we kind of got like more of a time
frame now they kind of expected like
look look at the Video Game Awards
you're going to get an announcement
there all I'm saying don't be surprised
if you see a shadow
drop that's what I think is gonna be
yeah don't be surprised if you see a
shadow drop let me get these super chats
real
quick we got we got $5 Super Chat from
Nintendo Don the ataku Nintendo dropped
14 first party games this year in the
show down year uh in the slow down year
Xbox and especially PlayStation need to
step it up I agree with you you know U
you know I think Xbox is you
know you might have a different term of
what I feel
like Nintendo first party is the me I
have Nintendo has had a a fantastic year
I will say that I'm not going to
downplay that but I don't consider
everything Nintendo
publishes I want to
play Nintendo games I don't know for a
fact but I'm assuming Nintendo games
first party games doesn't have the
budget or um doesn't take as much time
to develop as Playstation Xbox first
party games
meaning they can have more first party
games I feel like that gives them more
creative control though because it's
like we don't have to jump straight on
something we can actually take like six
months to Define what we want 100 I
agree 100% but at the same time Pokemon
sells more than Spider-Man and them and
it probably took a tenth of the of of of
the the the development cost hey that's
what you have to give Nintendo credit
for bro absolutely no doubt about the
amount of money that Nintendo's I think
I I saw Sega and Nintendo gave increases
to how much their employees make yeah
I'm sure Nintendo can for sure they're
they're they're putting 10 million into
a I know it's cost more 10 I'm just
joking they're putting 10 million down
dollars down in development process and
they're and they're getting 500 million
back like easy easy like let me ask you
this Zelda uh tears of the Kingdom how
much do you think that budget was I'm
thinking about 40 to 50
million maybe that's pushing it yeah
even that maybe they prob they probably
spend I would say 25 to 50 and they
spent probably 50 on
marketing trust me they already got that
back in the marketing they might not
even marketed that much because Zelda
bro Zelda is a wellknown IP okay
everyone everyone in the chat in the
chat we're gonna go over these super
chats real quick put in the chat what
you think the marketing budget not the
marketing budget the overall budget for
Zelda marketing and development cost
together put that in the chat I'm
curious you guys say let's go and get
these super uh Super Chat from Spartan
661 uh they buy ps5s to play Blu-ray
DVDs not games that's funny that's funny
then we got a $2 Super Chat from
pump dirt is The Dark Knight of Xbox hey
show some damn respect
pum all right so let's see what these
people think 150 million that's a lot no
no Trey bone bro no way is there did
have they ever commented on it let me
see if they have no I don't think
Nintendo T Walker said 75 million with
marketing I still think that's a little
much I don't know the Legend of Zelda if
if if a people made Super Mario
World I'm TR trust me these teams is not
no 200 person team making these games
bro maybe 100 person team I could be
wrong but I'm just right
so 120 Mill million is what Google said
estimates that it was with everything
like the development and the marketing
yeah okay I see that but and that that
could be like outdated information I
don't know I would say a 100 million
though because marketing is not cheap
like marketing is not cheap hey Doc dark
stupid I know a dude who works at Costco
that takes LSD can make Mario
one that's pretty funny yeah it's
just U doc we got to get you on the show
man you always in the chat but never in
the in the in the podcast man what's
that about what's that about got a
problem with us huh you don't like us
hey man I like your video earlier today
about the Xbox tax it was a good
video oh what's going on there man got a
problem with us you don't want to be
seen on on the attic show your brother
will clown on you you're trying to
you're trying to avoid the Xbox people
huh you'll pop in there a poto rock but
you know you won't come on lonely owned
attic show there's levels
at we're on the bottom level D we're on
the bottom level Tomy gotta be right
brother I know I'm just messing with you
$5 Super Chat from the angry therapist
one million it's Nintendo they see uh
they sell without uh marketing I I don't
think they sell without marketing but
they definitely you know it's crazy if
you
if you look at their games they don't
have voice acting they don't so they
don't have to really pay for that for
the most part they don't have M cap they
mo capping is very limited if any right
uh so I'm thinking 120 million what's
[__] I don't know man that's like you
remember the original Blair Witch yeah
they said that movie cost $10,000 to
make I was like
where i, yeah they said the budget that
was $10,000 of course it was very
profitable for them because they they
made Millions but I was like 10,000 I
could did that movie with a camera and
that have you ever thought about seeing
these development games and thinking how
did the Publishers think this is G this
is
it yeah uh breath of the wild was 120
million uh $5 Super Chat from D daku
birth of the wild was 120 million and
tears of the king spent more time in
development there's more uh that's more
than unchartered The Last of Us in
Horizon zero Dawn ghost of shishima Etc
y'all smoking what what were they doing
though like I'm not saying that there's
not a good possibility that they had
that these games are making like that
their marketings are this high or
anything last two was like 200 million
all I'm saying from a standpoint is like
these games don't run very well so may
maybe maybe they like they make the game
and they spin the rest of the
development cycle just making sure it
runs on the switch it's like they make
the game dirt I got it I got it they
spent three years making the game okay
now I spend three years making sure it
runs on the
switch it's I'm just curious I didn't
know I came across that number too 120
million so maybe breath of the wild
meent that because here's the thing
though breath of the
wild they pretty much use the exact same
map from from tears of the Kingdom but
they they highly modified I'm not going
to say it's the same map well but they
definitely added new areas and they
modified it so I think if they spent
more time they probably spent a lot of
time making sure that that building
feature didn't break the game at any
time because that building feature is
cool it is like T of the kingdom is is a
lit game it's a great game but I I don't
personally believe it's like a vast
improvement from tears uh from breath of
the Wild
all right so let's go Jesus let's go
back to bers gay three oh
[__] they oh let me get these super it's
these super chats dir they keep
derailing our
conversations okay y'all smoking yeah we
are we definitely not smoking $2 Super
Chat from bone slave shout out both of
y'all TTS what's up bone slave what's up
bone slave all right all right let's
attempt number three okay let's talk
about the fact that we're finally
getting Boulders Gate 3 and it's going
to be on the Xbox series s and x and the
fact
that it's probably gonna get Shadow
dropped on the Video Game Awards yeah I
totally believe that's what they're
going to do because they said it's
coming out in 2023 what better place the
shadow drop it at the
VGA cool here's the question do you
think
you think a Game Pass B comes with
this I know you're gonna ask that
question bro I don't know I don't I
don't think so I don't think so not not
initially no it'd be interesting here's
my mindset I feel
like the shadow drop theme makes
sense but if it was just a shadow drop
why not just say now like does it matter
part of me feels like they're trying why
just go on to say something's been
re-released on a platform wasn't on to
take
time it feels like that's a little
excessive now obviously I overthink
everything so that's fine you know it's
an issue in my relationship I overthink
everything uh but you're making a great
point though I see why go on there just
to say yo we're releasing a game that we
that uh you know we didn't make it in on
time and now you can play it uh that
that that's why it's kind of interesting
and you know it nine times at a time I
want to point this out it's not coming
to Game Pass I I do think nine times out
of 10 this doesn't happen but what
happens if it does dir what happens if
it does I think that's that's big the
possible Game of the Year dropping into
Game Pass day one I think would be huge
huge you think that would take a lot of
the spotlight away from the whole
event
um not
necessarily I think if it Wins Game of
the Year that's that's going to make
Xbox look even better because they could
promote it Game of the Year winner
balers gate three Dro Xbox yeah right
now yeah so um I don't know man it's
very interesting
bro I'm up here looking at this Justice
League game playay for this did you see
it no the more I I haven't been
interested in that since I found out
it's going to be a games as a service
yeah like I I love the idea of killing
the Justice League but then when they
put that games as a service I'm like
okay now I'm not excited like at all I'm
actually like the opposite here here's
my thing when it comes to
this maybe they have an expansion
already maybe that's why it's at the
Video Game
Awards um I don't know like to me it's
just interesting to come out there and
just okay we finally finished the game
it's coming out to today or tomorrow or
next week it it just it feels like
they're preparing you for
more and I probably wrong you know I I'm
just looking into this because is people
sat there and said well uh you know I
know they're gonna say Ad you're you're
on the same stuff you were when you
thought Allan Wake to was the day one
game pass because it was going to be uh
they ended the the last like little
direct thing that Microsoft did it's
like that was a legit question though U
why are they showing a launch title on a
direct the game's coming out in two days
I get it Allen wake 2 probably needed
that this could be a marketing thing but
it's
like bers gate three comparing to Allen
wake two entirely different ball games
yeah so I'm kind of I'm just curious I'm
curious on that uh regardless what
happens we're not going to find out uh
until until the video game are you
streaming that I don't know man I don't
know if you're not you know you're
welcome to come on ILP and stream react
I usually do I did the last two years
but this year I'm kind because you know
you know the copyrights you always get
because last year I actually avoided the
copyrights I kept on pressing mute yeah
I'm very I'm very big on the mute thing
yeah you're more than welcome to come on
and do it with us yeah I mean if I don't
do it you know my boy Sean will probably
do it but yeah that's fine you know if I
side you know I still might do it I'm
not sure right now yeah to be honest
with you's a lot of risk that goes into
to streaming anything to be honest yeah
I I feel like the industry's gotten
better but it guys got a little bit I me
Ubisoft used to block it like then he
used to block like Ubisoft used to block
people stuff yeah so I mean it is what
it is it is what it is let's let's go to
the the main event of the evening man
Main Event man we gonna talk about
Starfield and Game of the Year and this
is one hour and 13
minutes no not 12 13 I don't want the
time step Mafia on my ass this week oh
man you know time step Mafia Don't Play
bro yeah you know what's
funny they they don't appreciate all the
effort I I have to do this stuff live
interrupt the uh the theme interrupt the
the the pacing of the show just to make
you guys happy man just to make you guys
Happy put some logos in the chat show me
some appreciation yeah okay put some
logos in the chat and show me some
appreciation now I'm playing with you
guys uh I would appreciate if you hit
that like button though guys we got
almost 500 people in here hit that like
button hit the like button button I
sound really Cra Crazy saying I I will
never do that ever again I cringed at my
own voice
yeah all right so let's talk about it
Game of the Year nominations came
out actually you know what D you know
what we're gonna do this real fast real
real fast Game of the Year nominations
we're gonna go over some of these now
I'm I'm gonna be real with you guys I
don't care about the majority of these
Awards so don't expect us to go over
like a lot of them but we're going to go
over a few of
them me click this no it's this one
we're presenting screen
share the Video Game Awards bam do you
see it yes sir all right so we're gonna
leave the the game of the year last you
know we might actually go ahead and vote
on some of these what's the first one
you want to tackle
dirt it don't matter bro let's choose
one play this like Jeopardy I I take uh
best family for 300 okay is that
Jeopardy I think that's Jeopardy yeah
all right so best family Mario uh Super
Mario BR uh bro Bros wonders uh Sonic
Superstars what Sonic yeah I one about
it party animals and Disney illusion
either I'll probably say Super Mario
Brothers I haven't played none of those
games I play party animals for a quick
second best fighting I don't I don't
play with fighting
games for me Moral Kombat speet figh
Moral Kombat Mortal Kombat had a solid
experience
yeah best RPG the
only thing that starf you know I feel
like they gave I feel like they wanted
to give that to octopath traveler 2 so
much but they they didn't they they they
knew even though people were upset there
why if Starfield didn't get one
nomination yeah at least they gave me
one Starfield for me on that
one even though b g probably win I say
for me it's C of
stars yeah I haven't play because I I
consider Starfield an RPG but I consider
it less of an RPG than something like Co
Stars I think Co stars is more
traditional
RPG best action adventure for the best
action adventure game com uh combining
combat with traversal and puzzle
solving I I love how they put this
traversal thing in here like if you
really look at if you look at this and
you look at like the the text it's like
they're
screaming vote Spider-Man Spider-Man
yeah because the only other game that
has some traversal is Star Wars and
Zelda and yeah in Zelda but like I don't
even does Allan Wake to have that
no it barely has action
bro I mean there
some to me the the one that wins is Jedi
if you go off just this it's Jedi Jedi
has really good traversal and has got
better combat than all of these
games uh Zelda has better traversal but
I don't feel like its combat is better
than Star
Wars look at Nintendo donaco you act
like you you you ain't
biased I see you I see you best action
game for the best game in the action
genre uh Focus primarily on
combat give me that high five Rush on
that one I'm bu I think armor core yeah
I didn't play that but I heard it was
pretty good I didn't play it either but
I feel like armor core what I've heard
about it it fits this more than anything
high five Rush is really good too yeah
but I I've been told that the uh the the
combat in armored Core is really good
but I was such a that game was pretty
damn good bro I'm not talking about the
action but it was a damn good game yeah
and considering I thought you know it's
like I said on IP if you would have back
went back two years and told me that
dead RI uh uh
the island no not de Dead Rising no not
Dead Rising Dying Light 2 if Dead Island
2 was going to be a better game than
Dying Light I would have said you were
you I finished both games add I think is
is much better than better
100% uh we are skipping that one yeah
don't mind we're skipping that one damn
right we are we're skipping that one
skipping that
one it's because most of these games I
don't know SE Stars I know I I didn't
play this people say this is a good game
I don't I didn't play cocoon because of
stuff going on yeah uh I just don't know
those games and I feel like I If if
we're gonna have an engaging
conversation unless you know these games
hell no you know I know those games yeah
like
best best uh Community
Support why the hell is cyber punk in
this why this should be replaced with
Halo infinite
mhm I
agree and and how is Destiny 2 in here
like I don't understand how Destiny 2 is
in here like they literally just let go
their
entire their entire Community department
so how okay I guess laying them off like
the community itself isn't necessarily
saying the game's going to be worse but
to me it best ongoing awarded okay let's
let's read these because these are
important recognizing a gam for
outstanding Community Support
transparency and res uh responsiveness
okay it took them like three years to
fix this damn game or two so I guess
that's that's not responsiveness
inclusion of social media activity I'm
kind of curious that they even tweet
like
that I don't know I don't really keep in
game patch updates they've had like
they've had patches is but as far as
updates I wouldn't say they've had like
a drastic amount of them you know what
I'm saying I would say Boulders gate
deserves it over cyberp Punk cyber Punk
should even be there bro and okay now we
got best ongoing award to a game for
outstanding development of ongoing
content that evolves The players's
Experience over
time why the hell is cyk on this I'm
okay with every other game there except
for cyber Punk bro you could have
replaced that with Halo infinite or CF
thieves it's like they try to just
shoehorn this in
here I don't I don't get it all right it
is what it is gains for impact I don't
really know any of these games uh
accessibility uh I don't see I'm not
disabled in any way shape or form so
it's hard for me to like determine the
the accessibility in here and like to me
too all right obviously they're doing
nominations but it's only people that's
that has some form of disability going
to vote on this because to me having
people without disability voting on this
is kind of uh like insulting you know
what I'm saying it's like you don't have
disabilities how can you vote on a game
that caters to disabilities like to me I
feel like I would be more uh against
that if uh the people weren't disabled
but at the same time they're going to
get enough people to effectively have a
committee to vote on this as well you
know what I'm saying is it gonna be like
five people that are generally disabled
and the rest are not going to be
disabled like I it's just my biggest
issue with this D is the lack of let me
switch back here my biggest issue with
this is the lack of transparency we
don't know what the hell's going on we
don't know how these the these things
are chosen we have zero idea of how
anything of this happens how are we
aware that these people play it did you
see the coach ESP uh uh Esports two of
the people they nominated hasn't even
coached this year yeah I saw that how I
saw the guy say I'm I'm not even a
cult I saw that and then people are like
well adct the reason they don't show
them is because they don't want you
harassing them first off I'm not going
to harass anyone but I can understand
that that but clearly the people that
he's picking or or chosen I don't know
which one it is they're not they're
picking people that's not even active in
the industry right so clearly there's
something wrong there you I don't know
you let's let's just move Mo
on oh best performance I actually like
this I feel like there should be a
couple of
these you know um even have a you know
have a woman's one
too yeah all them them all together is
just is so
disappointing
um Ben star from Final Fantasy play
Clive he actually did a good job on that
I don't like the G but he did a good job
I want Cameron to
win because I see how passionate he is
and obviously all of them are probably
passion somebody say
y do you want to talk about that it
doesn't matter b are do you want to talk
about
that he hasn't unfollowed me on Twitter
yet well here's the thing okay all right
we we are dering the podcast once again
uh let's just finish and we'll we'll
we'll end with the Yong thing cuz I I do
want to talk about that uh now I kind of
want to rush through these here so we
could talk about
it uh best audio design Allen wake 2
dead space these are fine but I think
high five Rush deserves this one yeah
but played all of those play dead space
is good I play I beat all of those games
to have of Spider-Man 2o I'm still at
the beginning I haven't played it in
best music and score high-fi Rush again
that game has awesome music bro I don't
like Final Fantasy 16 as a game but it
does got a good
soundtrack best art
Direction um highi Rush again beautiful
yeah what did you
do it looks
good yeah so um I think high-f five rush
you know what's going to funny highi
Rush probably going to leave this with
the most
nominations I I believe they did what
had seven oh no I think Spider-Man had
more didn't they I'm talking about
winning them oh winning oh okay I got
yeah I I think it's probably not going
to outbeat the the game of the year
contenders but I bet you it beats one of
them because here's the thing when you
have these Game of the Year contenders
and they're in so many categories
they're going to get split there's a
there's a real where zeld only get one
damn
award because it's been such a stacked
year best
narrative um all right so final f he
deserves this is decent you know I don't
know about Spider-Man having best
narrative because it's kind of
like your standard Spider-Man story I
don't think it like differed anyway uh I
have been told like certain aspects that
hav't been done in comics so I can
understand that uh but you know even
with it being there I can understand why
it'll be there I just felt like there
was better games to put in a narrative
position than it uh but the rest I I I I
I feel do you feel yeah yeah I feel it's
fine yeah Island wake 2 I haven't played
but I've been told it's like a really
good narrative yeah yeah it's really
good but I still had to watch the video
I have to figure out what the hell was
going on best game Direction This Is
Where I highly disagree on and people in
the chat especially Nintendo Don the
otaku you can talk your [__] that's fine
Zelda and Spiderman do not deserve to be
on this
list because to me best game direction
is awarded for the outstanding Creative
Vision and inative in a game Direction
and design game direction is to me
changing things up these two games are
clones from their pre predecessors
exactly yeah does that make them bad no
they're they're fantastic games uh but I
don't believe these two games deserve be
on there because tears of the kingdom
was a very step in the right direction
but at the same time it is a lot of the
same stuff you play in breath of the
wild I don't feel like they changed it
enough
to go go into that that's just my
opinion Mario wonder I'm like on the if
if that should have come out here but I
do feel like they changed especially
with this wond seed thing they changed
that enough that makes me feel like okay
that this should be on here because when
you click those now look Zelda I feel
you Zelda debatable that's the one I
this Spider-Man here they gave you a
gliding suit and gave you some options
to to play that wasn't in the first one
this is literally a copy and paste great
game but it's copy and paste
nonetheless uh you know I will I can I
will understand an argument for Zelda I
don't agree with it but I would
understand an argument for Zelda I
personally feel like Starfield needs to
be in uh Spider-Man's place because
there's not a game really doing what
Starfield is doing is there games that
do something similar yeah but there's
not a game that does what Starfield is
doing right and to me
the fact that it didn't get on this list
is a slap in the face I personally feel
like they feel all these games every
game and game of the year has to be in
this category too it doesn't make
sense uh because if you look it's like
the same damn games except for they
added Resident Evil 4 to the match and
you can argue if if Resident Evil 4
should be here I don't think it should I
I think yeah I think
that we got to enough games that come
out every year that deserves a remaster
or remake
category and can easily fill it Dead
Space Resident Evil 4 uh uh Advanced
whatever that game is for the switch I'm
sure one of you guys can say it one and
two uh those games deserve to be on
there uh you can easily put this in
there you know you can actually say
Spider-Man 2 is a is a remat a remake of
Spider-Man one
I'm ADV Advanced Wars one and two yeah
that's it like I think that that should
have went maybe not even for Starfield
you know I I can see a huge argument
that's saying these games or Diablo was
a game that that could have easily took
it I'm not saying Starfield deserve to
be up here I just don't think Resident
Evil for deserve to be up here yeah at
all yeah hey he hey add so what does all
these games have in common third person
action adventure third person action
adventure third person action adventure
true but
they're all sequel all sequels bro they
all sequels I will bers gate three is a
cavat like this isn't this is a sequel
but it's not a sequel like it changed
everything about from The Originals yeah
but but it's still a sequel because this
is but I don't think it's the the the
tra it's it's the traditional sequel
they did change drastic things about
this game yeah but the name is a sequel
meaning if you like bers gate one or two
you might just pick it up strictly off
of the name
and I feel like they won't like it
because the the combat's different too
that's the funny part yeah true but this
is my point this stuff like this if if
these companies get incentives for
getting nominated for a game of the year
it gives these companies this right here
to me shows why some companies don't
want to gamble on new IP not just
because of like from a financial um um
point where these games are super
expensive and they really don't want to
gamble on a new IP because it might not
be you know like critically acclaimed
like some of these other games and when
you have a sequel people are most likely
if the first game did well they're most
likely to go get another know like the
sequel of that game so when you have six
sequels six sequels that's nominated for
Game of the Year excuse me do you see
game like Starfield high five Rush even
a game like Hogwarts Legacy I understand
you know like why people said it wasn't
nominated for whatever reason but the
game I know it's based on a very popular
franchise but is technically a new game
in the world that's known but a new game
but so these games I just feel that when
you constantly you know uh new IPS you
we're going to see less and less new IPS
out here bro if a game like Resident
Evil 4 remake which I love don't get me
wrong game was phenomenal I need to
actually play it I love resil play the
original well I never finished the
original one back in 045 whatever year
it was but when you see remakes getting
nominated for Game of the Year we're
want to continue to see
remakes and I like remakes for certain
games as long as it's you know far apart
like like Resident Evil was I don't
think that game should be nominated for
game of the year so I'm just telling you
guys right now we're going to see less
and less new
IPS because of stuff like this yeah and
that's why you know it's a good thing
that Ubisoft and Microsoft around
because it seems like they're you know
very open to to new IPS and okay let me
say something I'm sorry to C add but e-
ranks yeah you're right eldering was
definitely a new IP that's the exception
but I just feel we're going to see less
and less moving forward so you're right
about last year with elder ring yeah I
feel you let's let's move on to We're
not gonna talk about this long uh but
I'm curious to hear your opinion yo Yang
yay
how do you spell his name y y o n g ye E
A ye E
A we
are 1
hour 32
minutes all right so I assume you've
seen what I'm talking
about oh let me get these super chats
I'm sorry guys yeah um $5 Super Chat
from Nintendo d the talko they created
one of the most reust phys uh physics
engines and systems that 99% can't pull
off te the game took a even further
refuse an ultrah hand and incent I feel
you maybe that's the reason it does
deserve to be in that uh that uh you
know best game Direction but I feel like
that's what breath of the wild was
already doing they just gave you more
tools to do it but I I get it I'm not
going to argue with you about that
because I do think there is arguments
both sides people need to to give Phil
his props he said get at me and now the
game is coming out and the devs praise f
s yeah did he definitely he was like
look this they can do it they just got
to want to do it uh El elfrin bendex
efen bonitz yeah with $2 Super Chat what
if XBox buys a studio of breath in the
vtas that would be
crazy yo what happens if yo I know this
would never happen D I know this would
never happen but it would be funny they
come up there and the game of the year
is Boulders Gate 3 and every comes up
there and Phil comes up there and gets
to the they're now under Xbox game
studio just you just sit and you just
hear the the the the Star Wars theme
song and the Darth Vader theme
s it's like you guys said we couldn't
get a game of the year so we made sure
we had one so we bought one take
that we got $ Super Chat Nintendo Don
theotaku unlike these other nominees
that spent 70% of the budget on making
the best movie Nintendo puts all their
resources towards gameplay forward I
agree with them on that yeah they do
yeah they do hey oh I'm sorry go ahead I
thought you was done sorry yeah just a
couple more the angry therapist the $5
Super Chat I know how they make the pick
uh the pcks give everything and norm and
block Xbox games they know it can't make
sense uh but Xbox
tax oh go $2 Super Chat from Corey
Tidwell I'm voting for Molina because
she's fine that's the black woman in um
Alan W too yes she is
fine I can't oh okay I I don't I don't I
don't have a mental image of like her
her actual picture looks like yeah uh $5
Nintendo d the taco addict name one game
with the abilities like fuse Ascend and
recall you can only name
banel uh banjo the for Ultra hand stop
holding on to Old Zelda you're biased Dy
man why you coming after you like
that I can either confirm or deny I'm
bi we got a member chat for 33 months it
takes two one game of the year and
that's was a new IP yeah I want to talk
about that I did say moving forward um
of course like somebody put in there
Securo because I believe that won a
couple years ago right yeah yeah so yeah
and to be fair from software both Elden
ring yeah and so it from softare just
might be the you know they're the
outliner they're not the norm for the
industry yeah so that was my point I
said moving forward not necessarily um
you know well like in the past of course
you saw some new IP I just think today
where the gaming industry is where we
hear about a lot of layoffs I think a
lot of uh Publishers a lot of
developers are cautious on making huge
AAA IPS now I know eldering was the
exception it takes two that game was
phenomenal me and Sean finished that
game but that wasn't a triaa game either
it was a great game and that game
deserve game of the year because it was
really really good I just they moving
forward because like even a game like
days gone I actually like days gone a
lot I finished the game Play Station did
not want to gamble on making a sequel to
that game and nah nah we don't want to
do it I just like I said I just feel
that a lot of Publishers are kind of
afraid to gabble on no IP that's why I
like what Xbox is doing because with
Xbox game pass is not necessarily about
the sales of the game it's about the
engagement of the game so they will be
more likely to do a new
IP as opposed to some other uh
Publishers all right so let's uh let's
get the yay thing this won't take long I
assume you saw the yay thing you curious
your opinion on it like do you play
these type of games do you play dub more
you play sub like does this bother you
CU I feel like there's a lot of
variables that what would go into caring
about the kind of performance he does
yeah um if it's it sound pretty bad bro
I don't know if it would bother me
because I played plenty of games with
terrible voice acting like the original
Resident Evil that game was amazing and
from I'm talking the original one on the
PS1 the voice acting was horrendous but
that was back then and we had much
better voice acting in games um so I
would say I a little bit I was a little
bit disappointed with his performance
now he's obviously not an actor or a a
professional voice actor but damn you
know you the the people
that I saw someone upset because they're
like they feel like he got a lot of this
clout because of his existing clout from
YouTube um because I don't keep up with
that so I wouldn't know and I don't know
if you keep up with that but is it is a
little strange to you that someone that
has been in the the voice acting uh for
not too much long obviously he's been
training for it for a long time but it a
lot of people feel the need to say
like it's interesting he got such big
roll so
fast and I can understand that kind of
criticism it's like look like you know
obviously you guys saw when he was on
IOP you know I asked him straight out do
you think your existing clout had
anything to do with the the current uh
you know opportunities you're currently
getting and uh you know he kind of
pushed back and said know you know I've
been I've been you know kind of going
through I'm like look like I disagree um
it's not anything bad it's just I feel
like because of the people he's met
throughout his YouTube career people
knew him in those
rooms um you know I might be wrong but
to me you know it's crazy that he got
such a key role so fast and I
in I need to get more people in that
industry to find out exactly how it
functions because I feel like then we
can answer that question more like
honestly you know what I'm saying like
but right now we're not really we don't
got we don't know enough people and I
haven't talked enough people to really
understand if like it's out of the norm
for someone to get a role like that so
fast because I'm sure there's people
been in the industry for like 10 years
that could have gotten that role as well
yeah and did a better job but look I
think to um if he did get the road
because of his YouTube popular po it
good for him you know what I'm saying
and he built his YouTube channel that's
what I'm saying like I don't understand
like why he would get annoyed with that
now I get it like obviously that's not a
bad thing no it's not a bad thing I get
people are a little upset over it so you
know I can understand that when you look
at it from that standpoint where it's
like you know look at it from Yang yay
and I'm not going to sit there and Sugar
Code his performance I didn't like it at
all yeah um I thought he was just
talking it didn't feel like you know a
lot of voice acting going on there but
at it from his perspective I know he's
being emotional on Twitter he's blocking
people this is this dude's dream yeah
yeah yeah and he is being attacked by
literally an army like you could you
could take over California with the
amount of people attacking him right now
yeah bro he's but you know what that's
the that with the territory that comes
with the territory man like we're
YouTubers adct right and even when I had
40 Subs I knew that were going to be
people that talk trash about me they
were going to you know that just comes
with the
territory but you know we have the right
to block them if we want but of course
it's going to happen he uh if this is
his dream man you know I'm sure he'll
get better at it I'm sure his YouTube
channel helped him get clout or you know
talk to the right people and like I said
not even necessarily clout just people
know who he is yeah absolutely man will
you be surprised on how well you can Ro
move in the room just to people know who
you are like they don't even have to
know you personally not even just hear
your name like cuz imagine like 5,000
people fill out a job application you
see y yay I don't know if that's his
real name or not but you know you see
that I would assume that would help oh I
know this dude is this that a
YouTuber and you know I feel like that
would help now people you know they are
making statements on like you know his
criticism towards Chris uh Chris Pratt
totally valid you know he he should have
just kept his mouth
shut because you know when we saw that
you know K it's like that ain't that
that ain't it yeah apparently he's gonna
be a Persona three yeah I mean look man
good good for the guy like I said I hope
he gets better at voice acting you know
because I was watching a commercial the
other day a Subway commercial and I
heard NBA former NBA player Charles
Brockley doing the voice over I was like
why do they need celebrities to do
voiceovers for commercials where you
don't physically see them they can have
anybody do a voice over but go back to
your point people recognize his voice
because I recognize his voice instantly
oh that's Charles Barkley talking so
because he has a name he has a pretty
big Channel like don't he get million
subs or two three million 2.5 million or
something like that not a small YouTuber
yeah that's a pretty big YouTube channel
so I understand why he I said former NBA
players quickly what are you talking
about I um so I understand why he was
able to get the job but you know I'm
sure he'll get better at his craft
hopefully I feel you and we're gonna go
ahead and uh you know end with that it's
like I said at the end of the day you
know I just hope that he improves his
performance and you know I want him to
shut us up not like not try to shut us
up it's like dude if you don't agree
with our opinions make your next
performance so good that there ain't
[__] we could say about it you know what
I'm saying like yeah that's that's what
he do I was laughing what he said hey
hey know some big old women in San
Antonio them big old women that I'm
sorry that's something Charles barley
said and uh efen Bonz just talking about
that in the chat sorry about that
bro talking about the women in San
Antonio
big I was like come on man yeah so I'm
going go and end the show d man what
could people find you at hey with you
thank you man uh check out my Channel
Good Old D griggy I have a podcast on
Monday called wbg Xbox podcast and also
I have a oneman podcast on Thursday
evenings at 6 PM called Onan Darkman
podcast going to have a good show
tomorrow talking about some of the stuff
that's going on in the industry in the
community so that's about it man I feel
you can find me on YouTube at gaming
addict you know I I have been uh putting
out some a lot of content you know
people people say addict how do you put
out so much content it's like when I get
up it's like one of the first things
that like I prioritize like okay I can't
really do much until at least I I my
biggest thing is I try to find out what
I'm gonna make a video about you know
what I'm saying that's that's always the
biggest thing bro now sometime I already
know what my video is tomorrow because I
was going to make the video today
but uh news about the boulders gate
thing came out and it's like I'm
treating I Tre like I'm I'm a new SL
opinion Channel I'm GNA pivot a little
bit uh but you know I'm enjoying I'm
enjoying the content I make obviously
people didn't like my FL did you see my
thumbnail for
yesterday um flawed or
corrupted no I didn't see that yeah is
is the Video Game Awards is it flawed or
corrupted oh yeah did see that I I did
say that I didn't get a chance to watch
the video yet though yeah people got
really upset with that people really get
really upset and that's fine you know uh
we we we'll see how they feel next year
been been been a hectic year man what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna send you guys
over there uh let me see who who who do
we have access to
today let's see you guys over there to
to to
fame good old Fame yeah go in there tell
them uh
adct show sent you and we'll see you
guys next week man go and Sub Sub sub to
dark G and follow him on Twitter too
yeah follow me on Twitter he's got
Twitter
follower see you guys later peace all
right yo peace
out